المترجم: Geo Mohammed Hassan
المدقّق: Anwar Dafa-Alla
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله الوالي الكريم حق حمده
ونصلي ونسلم على مولانا وحبيبنا محمد
رسوله وعبده وعلى آله وصحبه
السلام عليكم وعلينا
وعلى عباد الله الصالحين
سعيد جداً أن أشارك في هذا اليوم
ﻷتحدث عن (أُمْ دُرمان)
والذي ينبغي أن يُعرف عن (أُمْ دُرمان)
"وخيرُ بنيك يا سودانُ مني،
سلوا الحادي سلوا الشادي المغنّي"
(أُمْ دُرمان) التي سأتحدث
بطريقه القصة و الدردشة
(أُمْ دُرمان) التي سأتحدث عنها
هي (أُمْ دُرمان) واحد
و(أُمْ دُرمان) الثانية
و(أُمْ دُرمان) الثالثة الحالية
(أُمْ دُرمان) اﻷولى هي
(أُمْ دُرمان) التاريخية القديمة جداً
والتي فيها إنسان العصر الحجري الحديث
وعاش هذا اﻹنسان على ضفاف
خور (أبو عنْجَة) الموجود بالقرب من هنا
وآثاره موجوده حتى اليوم في خور
(أبو عنْجَة) منطقه الجير
بالقرب من (الجامعة اﻷهلية) و بإمكانكم
أن تجدوا عدداً قليلاً من سكاكينه الحجرية
ومواقد وآلات عظميه وأسلحه
اﻹنسان القديم
وهو امتداد ﻹنسان (الشِهْيَناب) الموجود
في شمال (أُمْ دُرمان) وإنسان (الخُرْطوم)
الذي وجدت أثاره في مكان
(مستشفى الخُرْطوم)
وهناك إنسان (أُمْ دُرمان) أيضاً
الذي وجد غرب كبري (أُمْ دُرمان)
باﻷسفل في مكان (السلاح الطبي) هذه هي
(أُمْ دُرمان القديمة) التاريخية الموجودة
آثارها حتى اﻵن وأمّا (أُمْ دُرمان) في
عهد (التركية) كانت عباره عن حاميه
في منطقه (السلاح الطبي) والبرلمان اﻵن
والمجلس الوطني وكانت آخر صيانة
لهذه الحامية بواسطه حكمدار (السُّوُدان)
(عبد القادر باشا حلمي)
وكانت قد اندلعت (الثورة المهدية)
وبدأت معركه (الجَزِيرة أبَا)
وانتهت
بعدها معارك الغرب
طبعاً، خاضت (المهدية) ست معارك
شهيره آخرها معركه تحرير (الخُرْطوم)
فتمت الصيانة وكان القائد المسؤول
من حاميه (أُمْ دُرمان التركية)
هو (اليوس باشا فرج الله محمد) وأسرته
ما زالت موجودة بيننا في (أُمْ دُرمان)
أحفاد أحفاده موجودين
في منطقة حي الضباط
(أُمْ دُرمان) في عهد (المهدية)
هي (أُمْ دُرمان) الثانية
وهي (أُمْ دُرمان) التركية
(أُمْ دُرمان) الثانية
وفي (أُمْ دُرمان) الثانية كان
(اﻹِمِامْ المَهْدِي) عليه السلام
يجلس تحت (شجره الحَضْره) خلف
(السلاح الطبي) جهة (ديم أبو سِعِد)
أو (ديم الفِتِيحاب) وقرر الهجوم على
(الخُرْطوم) بعد حصارها كل تلك الفترة
عندها قال لمن حوله "سأجعل عاصمة الدولة
الإسلامية المهدية الجديدة في بُقْعَةٍ لم
تسكن من قبل، أرض بكر لم يرعَ فيها حيوان،
عندما تقف على أرضها يكون نجم (الدو-بران)
أعلى رأسك مباشرةً" (والدُوبْرَان)
هو ونجم كبير وقديم في برج الثور
ويسمى بعين الثور وهو نجمٌ أحمرٌ، لا
فعندما يكون محمر معناها أنه نجم قديم
قارب على الانفجار وقال أن "قبلتك للصلاه
ستكون على النيل" قال هذا الكلام للناس
ولم يكن يعلم أحد من الناس
أين سوف تكون هذهِ (البُقْعَة) البكر
التي ليس فيها حيوان رعى أو إنسان
قد سكنها من قبل ولكن اتضح بالنهاية
أن البقعة هي جزء من قلب (أُمْ دُرمان)
الحالية فاﻹمام (المهدى) عندما كان قادماً
من ديم أبو سعد راكباً ناقته فبركت الناقه
في مكان القبة حالياً (قُبَّه اﻹمام المهدي)
(أُمْ دُرمان) عندما قدم إليها
اﻹمام المهدي وكما يقال "كَبَرْ شَدَرَها"
كانت عباره عن أشجار من نوع (اﻷكاسيا)
أشجار وشجيرات وقام على أمر نظافتها
وأعتمدها كعاصمةٍ للدولة المهدية الجديدة
ويمر عبر (أُمْ دُرمان) أحد عشرة خور
وشكلها عبارة عن صحن صُحفة
مرتفعة من الاتجاه الغربي ومنحدرة تجاه
هذا النيل بمعنى مائلة نحو الشرق ومرتفعة
نحو الغرب محاطة بحدوه جبال
تبدأ من الشمال بجبل (جُهَم) ومن بعده جبل
(سُرْكاب) ومن بعده (الجبل اﻷزرق)
فجبل (كَرَرِي) (فالمَرْخِيَاتْ) وتنتهي
في جبل (طُوُرِيَّة) في الجهة الجنوبية
على شكل هلال يحجزها من الخلف
ومن الجهة اﻷخرى النيل
و(أُمْ دُرمان) القديمة، كانت كل المنطقة
ولكن البقعة تختلف عن (أُمْ دُرمان)
كما ينبغي أن يعلم الناس، وهي جزء
من (أُمْ دُرمان) وتعني القطعة
من (أُمْ دُرمان) هذه (البُقْعَة)
كما قلت لكم تحوي أحدى عشر خور
الخور الجنوبي هو خور (غِرَانْفِيلْ باشا)
الذي يمتد من جهة (سلاح المهندسين)
بالخلف ويقطع الشارع خلف
(قصر الشباب واﻷطفال) و(دار الدبلوماسيين)
ويمر بمبنى (البرلمان) من الشمال
وجنوب (مسجد النيِلَيْن)
هذا الخور ربما معلوم للناس هذا هو خور
(غِرَانْفِيلْ باشا) وكان قائد الجيش
في زمن اﻹنجليز وسمى الخور باسمه
ولو مررتم اﻵن بالشارع المتجه غرباً بعد
(قصر الشباب) ستجدون محول كهربائي
كبير مكتوب عليه (محطة غِرَانْفِيلْ)
وفي هذا الخور، من الشمال كانت توجد بيوت
(اﻷمير حَمْدَانْ أبو عَنْجة)
وخور (أو عَنْجة) لم يسمى عليه
ﻷنه سكن بالقرب منه ولكن في
حصار (أبو عَنْجة) (للخُرْطوم)
في مكان (البوستة) "البريد"
وجعل مكان (بيْت السمك) كرسيه ورفع رجلاً
فوق اﻷخرى يراقب الحاكم العام
من خلال التلسكوب وكان يحاصره بعدما أسقط
حامية (أُمْ دُرمان) كان يعاين مكان السرايا
أثناء حصاره (للخُرْطُوم) وكان قد وضع
كرسيه في مكان مكتب (بريد الموردة) حالياً
ولذلك سمى الخور بخور أبو عنجة
بعد هذا الخور يوجد خور ثاني
وهو خور (الموردة) هنا بجهة "الريفيرا"
أيضاً الخور المار من جهة مسجد اﻷدارسة
(بالدَّايَاتْ) "مستشفى الولادة" وأيضاً
الخور الرابع خور (بَخِيِتْ الجُوْخْ)
وهو رجل فيلسوف كان يعيش في هذا الخور
من تحت الكبري ويقع الخور اﻵن جنوب
(المحطة الفضائية) وتلفزيون (الخٌرْطُوم)
وشمال هذه المحطة أو الخور مكان
(المسرح القومي) كان سجن (للمهدية)
وكان مسؤول منه (إدْرِيسْ السَّايِر)
وتوجد بقية الخيران عابرة إلى أن تلتقي
بالخور القادم جنوب المستشفى وشمال
(بيت الخليفة) وينحني حول
(إسطبل السَّوَارِي)
في اتجاه (المٌلازْمِين) ومستشفى
(المٌلازْمِين) وهنالك الخور اﻵخر يمر شمال
(مستشفى أُمْ دُرمان) وهو خور كبير جداً
ويستمر إلى أن يصب في النيل
وكل هذه الخيران تأتي من الغرب في طريقها
إلى البحر أو النهر وليس هنالك إشكالية
أن ندعو (نهر النيل) بالبحر أو النهر ﻷن
الله سبحانه وتعالى قال
"..بحران هذا عذب فرات وهذا ملح أجاج"
فمن الممكن أن نطلق كلمة البحر
على المالح والعذب والخيران تتواصل إلى
أن تنتهي في آخر خور ثم يظهر خور السوق
من أمام (سوق الشجرة) و(أبو رُوُف)
وكذا ومن ثم خور (الكَبَجَاب) وهنالك أيضاً
منطقة أثرية منطقة لصناعة الفخّار من
العصر الحجري القديم وهي منطقة
(القَمَايِر) (فأُمْ دُرمان)يمر خلالها
إحدى عشرة خور بالعرض وهنالك
ما بين الخور الرابع والخور السابع
كانت تقع (بُقْعة) اﻹمام (المهدي)
وهى الجزء الشمالي منها
(بُحيْرة اﻹمام المهدي) والجزء الجنوبي
منها هو (بوابة عبد القيُّوم)
وكانت هذه (أُمْ دُرمان المهدية)
ومضى اﻹمام (المهدي) عليه السلام
سريعاً جداً في يونيو عام 1885 للميلاد
واستلم القيادة من بعده الخليفة
السيد (عبد الله بن السيد محمد)،
وقام بتخطيط (أُمْ دُرمان) بطريقة
جميلة جداً، فلو وقفت (ببيت الخليفة)
واضعاً ظهرك على جدار بيت أو قصر الخليفة
وقمت بمد ساعديك هكذا فسوف تقسّم المدينة
على جزأين شمال وجنوب وعندما تقوم بعكس
الاتجاه ناحية الجنوب بمد يديك بذلك تكون
قسّمت (أُمْ دُرمان) إلى أربع أقسام
أو أربع حارات فأصبح (ﻷم درمان)
جزأين شماليين وآخرين جنوبيين
وقام الخليفة (عبد الله) بتخطيطها
في شكل (زَرَائِب) كل قوم لديهم زريبة
(كزَرِيبَة الكاشف) وقام بإسكان الناس
حسب القبائل التي ينحدرون منها وكما
تعلمون يا أحباب يتكون (فالسُّوُدان)
من خمسمائة إحدى وثمانون قبيلة منها
أربعمائة وسبعة عشر قبيلة في الشمال
ومائة وتسعة وستون قبيلة في الجنوب
وسبعة وخمسون قبيلة مشتركة بيننا
وبين دول الجوار وتسعة وستون أخرى
ليس لدينا معها جوار ولكن أفرادها
موجودون هنا (كالفُولَاني) على سبيل
المثال و(الفَلّاتَة) وكي لا ندع هذه
النقطة المهمة (فالسُّوُدان) فيه خمس
قبائل من غرب (إفْرِيقيا) شاركت معنا
في بناء نهضة (السُّوُدان)
و(السُّوُدان) الحديث
وهي (الفُولَاني) و(الهَوْسَا)
و(البَرْنْو) و(الزَبَرْنَا) و(البَرْقُو)
وهى قبائل محترمة جداً وأناسها
محترمون وأنتم كشباب يجب أن لا يكون
بينكم أي نوع من التمييز العنصري
أو أي نوع من الاضطهاد للقبائل ﻷنه
كل إنسان عزيز بقبيلته
(تصفيق)
ويجب أن تسقطوا هذه المسألة
وهذه لقبائل عزيزة جداً والكلام
عن (أُمْ دُرمان) في ثمانية عشر دقيقة
لا تكفيني أنا أحب (أُمْ دُرمان) وأتدفق
كالماء من أفواه القرب وكلام كثير يزدحم
برأسي وأحتاج لثمانية عشر سنة ﻷتكلم عن
(أُمْ دُرمان)
(تصفيق)
(فالسُّوُدان) عظيم وهذه
الخمسمائة وإحدى وثمانون قبيلة في
زمن (المهدية) أتت كلّها (لأُمْ دُرمان)
ولربما تكونون قد سمعتم بمعركة (كَرَرِي)
والتي لم تتحملها جيوش (المهدية)
كلّها وتحمّلتها فقط حامية (أُمْ دُرمان)
المكونة من خمس وستون ألف
وخطط الخليفة (أُمْ دُرمان) تخطيط
جميل جداً وكانت شوارعها نظيفة
وكان الناس يأكلون أكلاً جيداً جداً
كانوا يأكلون اللحم الشواء بالزبدة والفرصة
ويشربون اللبن ويأكلون العصيدة بالروب
وأنتم هل تجدون شيئاً من ذلك؟
لا أعتقد هذا!
(ضحك)
وكانت (أُمْ دُرمان) جميلة جداً
ونظيفة جداً وكان يرأسها محافظ
يسمّى بالعريف وهو أحد حكماء
الدولة (المَهَديَّة) وأحد حكماء
(السُّوُدان) هو (اﻷمير يعقوب أبو زينب)
وهو أحد حكماء (فالسُّوُدان)
والدولة (المهدية)
وكان مسؤولاً ومعتمداً على (أُمْ دُرمان)
وكان مسؤولاً عن اﻷمن والشرطة
(اﻷمير محمد حسين وَهْبِيْ) وكان معه
قوة لحراسة (أُمْ دُرمان) ولحمايتها
وأحياء (أُمْ دُرمان) في زمن (المهدية)
مسماة بأسماء القبائل، (أبو رُوُفْ)
هؤلاء هم أبناء (ود أبو رُوُفْ)
(الرُّفَاعَة)، (ودْ نُوبَاوِيْ)
(للأمير مُحمَّد وَدْ نُوبَاوِيْ)
(بَنِيْ جَرَّارْ)، (حَيْ العُمْدَة)
(للعُمْدَةْ السيَّد مَقْبُولْ العَوَضْ)،
(الرِّكَابِيَّةْ) هم (الرِّكَابِيَّةْ)،
(المَسَالْمَةْ) وهم من كانوا موجودين
منذ عهد (التُرْكِيِّةَ) وأسلموا في زمن
(المَهَدْيِّةَ) وتغنوا بهم في
"يا ظبية المسالمة و فيكي يا ظالمة
يا الفي الخمائل حالمة و فيكي
يا ظالمة و يا ظالمة و يا ظالمة"
(ضحك)
و(حَيْ العَرَبْ) "إتنين خمسة حارتنا"
(حَيْ العَرَبْ) حيث اﻹبداع وحيث
الفن وحيث الشعر والجمال والموسيقى
في (حَيْ العَرَبْ) ألم يقل الشاعر
"تلقى الدنيا باسمة واﻷيام طرب
هنا في حي العرب"
(أُمْ دُرمان) فيها (العُمَرَابْ)
"أن قلبي ذاب يا العُمَرَابْ"
وقد تغنوا كثيراً كما في تغنوا
في (القَلْعَة) "يا بدور القَلْعَة وجوهرا"
وفيها (المُوَرَدَة) ولم تكن (بَانَتْ)
موجودة وتم تأسيسها في الخمسينات
قريباً وكنا نقول لها الرجال بانوا
لما الناس أتوا ليبنوها وكانت خلاءا
وكان في (أُمْ دُرمان) في زمن
(المَهَدْيِّة) أربع (عَرْضَاتْ) بمعنى
أربع ميادين للاستعراض وكانت (العَرْضَه)
اﻷساسية مكان (مركز الشباب واﻷطفال) اﻵن
والذي يقع شرق (القُبَّه) وبالقرب من
(حوش شِيخْ الدِّينْ)
ولهذه سُميّت (بعَرْضَةْ المَهَدِيْ)
وكان (عبد القَادِر سَلَاطِيِنْ)
يجري بالجواد ويقول كلاماً فذهب الناس
(لخليفة المَهَدْيّ) ليقولوا له: يا سيدي،
هل سمعت ما الذي يقوله
(عبد القادر شَوَاطِيْنْ) (سَلَاطِيِنْ)؟
فسألهم عما قال، فقالوا له أنه يقول
"أنا المصيبة المعلقة بالسبيبة كان
إنقطعت السبيبة، تقع المصيبة!"
فقال (الخليفة) دعوه! وكان يثق به،
ولكن كان (الخليفة) شديد الذكاء،
فكان يأتيه جواباً من الخارج
باللغة اﻹنجليزية فينادي (لسَلَاطِيِنْ)
"يالفقير أقرا الجواب دا كدي
وريني قال شنو" ويقوم سلاطين بقراءة
الجواب بالكامل ويترجمه (للخليفة عبد لله)
وكان بيته في ركن (دار حِزْبْ اﻷُمَّه)
فيترجم الخطاب ويقوم (الخليفة)
بوضعه تحت فراء مجلسه ويقول له
"خلاص أمشي يا الفقير" فيذهب
وبعد ثلاث أيام يرسل (لسَلَاطِيِنْ)
مره أخرى "أيا سلاطين يا عبد القادر
الجواب اليومتا القلت ليك أقراهو
يومتا نسيتو! كدي أقراهو تاني!"
فيقوم بقراءته مره أخرى
فلو قام (سَلَاطِيِنْ) بتغيير حرف واحد
في الترجمة السابقة، يقوم (خليفه المهدي)
بتأنيبه "إنتا قبيل ما قلتا كدا
ليه قلت اﻵن كدا؟" فكان (الخليفة)
يتعامل بذكاء شديد وبالنهاية اتضح
أن سلاطين خائن
وعمل السيف والنار وانتقم كثيراً جداً
من (المهديه) فالمهم أن في
(المَهَدِيَّه أُمْ دُرمان) كانت جميله
ونظيفه ومنظمه وكلّها قبائل ومن بعد
ذلك جاء اﻹنجليز فقاموا بتقسيم
(أُمْ دُرمان) بنفس تقسيم (المَهَدِيَّه)
ﻷربع حارات فكانت (الحارة)
واحد هي (أبو روف) و المناطق السفلى
والحارة إثنين وهى غرب (شارع الخليفة)
والحارة ثلاثة وهى (المُوْرَدَه)
و(المُلَازْمِيْنْ) و(فَرِيْقْ رِيِدْ)
والحارة أربعه (العَبَّاسِيِّه)،
وتقسّم الحارة ﻷربع أرباع والربع
يحتوي على ثمنين فتصبح الحارة
بثمانيه أثمان "بلومبيرجز" اعتبر
(سُوُقْ أُمْ دُرمان) كثمن حاره
ووضع بها نقطه شرطه سمّاها (التُمْنَه)
ﻷنها ثمن حاره وعمل (ظَبْطِيَّه)
وهى مكان (الظَابِط) أو الضابطيه
وهي مكان المجلس الموجودة بها
والكلام يكثر عن (أُمْ دُرمان)
ولكني أرى أنهم أشاروا لي برفع
راية النهاية، شكراً جزيلاً
(تصفيق)